welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of thor 11
thunder's final trailer which has all of
us screaming like this guy
now that we are closer to the release
marvel studios always starts to tease
bigger pieces of the plot but hey i can
assure you i have seen the movie and
this footage doesn't at all spoil any of
the best parts of the movie and neither
will i in this video my speculation
drive has been switched off so i will
just be pointing out details noticeable
to anyone regardless of whether or not
they've seen the film and i'm just going
to explain their connections to marvel
comics and what they tell us about the
mcu beyond what happens in this movie so
again no love and thunder spoilers in
this video also this video is sponsored
by raid shadow legends more on them
later first we got a new shot of gore in
the chamber other shots i've shown jane
and thor inside of containing statues of
the living tribunal the watcher death
eon and infinity maybe more statues it's
a very important location i won't say
much more about it in this video but
then we get a few new shots of thor and
jane and valkyrie's exit from the
pantheon of gods that we thought would
be called olympus but an official clip
that we'll talk about later in this
video defines as omnipotence city the
promo i broke down in the past week
actually shows a glorious exterior shot
of omnipotent city as thor's goat boat
the egger departs on a makeshift rainbow
bifrost bridge thor's feet and the
others boots are coated in this
gold-colored blood of the guards of the
city that various footage shows
splashing everywhere and i love how thor
leaves a gold colored footprint on the
deck but as this boat flies out of the
smashed window it passes two celestials
we can actually identify who these are
just based on their appearance on the
left with the five eyes and the antlered
head is a mad celestial from the 2012
fantastic four comics set in an
alternate universe of earth 4280 these
celestials try to use reed richard's
bridge device it is an alternate reality
viewer they're trying to take for the
multiverse with this thing but they end
up getting defeated by reed's son
franklin richards and teaming up with
galactus now franklin richards is
actually implied to exist in the mcu in
universe 838 when reed richards
referenced having children please
i have children of my own i understand
your pain
is their mother still alive
yes
good
there will be someone left to raise them
the celestia on the right matches the
design of a celestial gardener from a
2013 uncanny avengers storyline set in
earth 616 when some celestials were
revealed to plant life seeds in death
seeds within planets along with tiamat
to the dreaming celestial from other
comics storylines like this inspired
ereshim's celestial seed plot in the
eternals film the fact that these two
are peeking through a window like
neighbors hoping for a slice of pie
gives us a sense of their scale like
other mcu celestials have been way
bigger than this bigger than planets so
these must be smaller like if they turn
their heads as this boat passes through
them they're definitely smaller than
airship is if they can fit inside of
omnipotent city and the fact that they
are here tells us that this whole
pantheon of gods isn't really a who's
who of the gods but really anyone who
has once had god status gets invited to
the party but let's talk about what you
need badass champions check tough bosses
check millions of players check years of
content and regular updates check and
check rage shadow legends has it all
caught in the middle of an epic struggle
that's raged for thousands of years
you'll fight noble kings and dark
wizards you'll uncover prophecies curses
betrayals and mean more than 12 warring
factions this game brings back
everything i remember about my childhood
and with gameplay i can take anywhere in
fact i remember where it all began with
ray i never expected to get this level
performance out of a mobile game
honestly look how crazy wow look at me
when i still cared what my hair looked
like and being slightly less sweaty and
as confident as i felt then i still look
a little nervous when i'm presenting
videos how far i have come well back
then that was maybe one out of four
videos we made that week now we're
releasing dozens per week how are we
managing it all we have really
appreciated raid's sponsorship over the
years and has helped us bring you more
of the content you love and much like
our channel raid does not stand still
it's constantly improving and has
developed and changed a lot with regular
new updates and content there's so much
to enjoy in this game i like going to
the tavern to summon different champions
to build out my collection there are so
many champions to collect some of my
favorites are ursine ironside he's a
giant bear ready for war there's also
brachus a shifter arch mage helmet and
crela witch arm all of them with unique
moves and abilities and there's just a
ton happening in a raid this month
they've got special events every single
day including an entirely new event for
summer solstice it's called the path of
light and you'll be able to explore
three branching paths to get the rewards
you want the most on top of that there's
some awesome new champions coming out
and a set of skins for the amazing
trenda guilt mallet they look amazing
and i can't wait to get my hands on them
ray it's currently running a special
delania chase event where you can get
your hands on the amazing delania brand
new legendary champion from the high
elves faction just by logging in all you
gotta do is log in and play raid for
seven days between now and july 20th and
you'll get delania for free that's it
delany is one of the strongest support
champions in the entire game you can
help carry your team and get past many
of raid's tougher challenges you don't
want to miss her this is the best time
to get started in raid and if you click
my link in the description or scan my qr
code here on the screen you'll get a
free starter pack worth almost thirty
dollars we're talking a free champion
aina 200 000 silver one energy refill
one xp boost and one ancient shards so
you can summon awesome champions as soon
as you get in game all this treasure
will be waiting for you right here it's
that easy just click the link in the
description and i will see you in the
game and if you're a new player you can
also use a special promo code for my
delania for some additional prizes get
50 xp brews to instantly get your
legendary hero delania to max level 50.
as well
but then a new shot of korg shows an
interesting looking deity to the right
behind him colored teal gray with an
elaborate golden feathered headdress
since bost bastet is sitting among these
based on the official photo that was
released several weeks ago i speculated
then that also among these could be
other members of the council of godheads
from the comics including the mayan
deity of insomna this guy looks a lot
like it somna as we wait for a trailer
for black panther wakanda forever and
the rumored reveal of namor with a
jaguar inspired look in mayan roots
because nakuerta said that he had to
learn a mayan language for this role
this guy in third level thunder could be
to him what boss is to black panther
another new shot shows thor with the
guardians on their ship the benatar
reviewing a star map holo display
showing disaster calls of which there
are 1567
and counting clearly gore has been
getting busy the display shows the star
map is a 3d concentric map organized
into these jigsaw sectors which i find
interesting because they could be the
political boundaries of the galaxy one
sector for the cree territory one sector
for the zandarian territory etc etc
battle lines and maps that could be
redrawn as the marvels explores a war
between the kree and the skrull and a
cree invasion of earth check out my
recent breakdown of the latest episode
of miss marvel for my explanation of how
all this could connect we learned that
thor's goats tooth grinder and tooth
nasher are gifted to thor to thank him
for saving this tribe so who knows where
these goats come from originally we see
two grinder and close-ups screaming at
the camera his buck teeth showing his
eyes in total chaos tooth nasher kicks
over a table sitting rocket and mantis
tumbling and i like how villa glows in
the background thor is grinning ear to
ear at this and we see a great shot from
the battle that all these people are
involved with thor doing to jean-claude
van damme split pose to stop the two
chariots and then his handshake with
peter quill human handshake
it's the asgardian shake
into the snake
that you cannot trust
really dragging this out let's finish
the classic asgardian high one
yeah thor is a reference to an
untrustworthy snake is a callback to a
past experience with loki he told the
story in ragnarok this one time a real
children he he transformed himself into
a snake and he knows that i love snakes
so i went to pick up the snake to admire
it and he transformed back into himself
and he was like yeah it's me and he
stabbed me let's move on to a new scene
released on jimmy kimmel live with tessa
thompson in the shadow realm how do you
know the atmosphere there has a darkness
like no other it's as if color feels to
tread it's unmistakable
well then if it's color we need
let's bring the rainbow
bring the rainbows at catchphrase or
something she's only been a thor for a
minute i mean saving lives she's quite
good at but the rest of it she needs
work how many catchphrases have they
been a lot
yep
jump the gun hang on he moves through
shadows and he's going to the shadow
realm it seems like that's where he's
gonna be the most powerful you're right
we can't just go marching in there it
could be a trap are you thinking what i
think you're thinking i'm thinking it
what are we thinking thinking we're
taking it too i'm living
so some important terms established here
let's define them without spoiling
anything in the plot beyond what was
said in this scene don't worry so the
shadow realm is a deep cut from marvel
comics strange fantasy comics in 1960
with the thing the shadow realm was
ruled over by a guy named kah who used
warriors in the forms of living shadows
thor love and thunder is using the
shadow realm to replace gore the god
butcher's original medium in the comics
as the bearer of all black the
necrosword previously a part of the
symbio deity no null and all derived
symbiotes like venom are sony properties
so that really limited the way the mcu
could depict gore in this movie but this
idea of the shadow realm is pretty cool
because it implies gore can use any
shadow to move in and out of a space
similar to the way the scarlet witch
could manipulate the mirror dimension to
enter and exit through any reflective
surface since shadows are literally the
absence of light shadows by their nature
have no color in them contrastingly at
the other end of the spectrum white
light is literally all the colors in the
spectrum merged and combined so shadow
is none of those colors visible since
gore moves through this shadow realm
that explains why he is desaturated and
we come back to omnipotent city this is
actually from the comics 2012 god of
thunder the same storyline that leads
into the mighty thor comics that this
movie is based on this city was first
constructed by the lords of the dawn the
first elder gods maybe their forbearers
a place of divine fellowship and a nexus
of all the gods it is built with the
trimmings of the clay of creation fired
with the embers that lit the first sun
to honest with you i love this kind of
[ __ ] in the comics i also like how this
clip shows jane foster as the mighty
thor particularly thirsty for a new
catchphrase which in this case is let's
bring the rainbow which definitely
sounds too close to the skittles tagline
of taste the rainbow at this point folks
i will be scaling back how many thor
videos i make now that we are in the
final stretch before the release it's
hard to talk about this movie without
spoiling it obviously so hang tight stay
tuned for our other content about the
digital release for multiverse madness
i'm doing a re-breakdown of that folks
as well as our breakdown for the ms
marvel episodes and everything else
follow me at ea boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you